I JUST FINISHED EPISODE FOUR.
-OK. SO THE LANNISTERS
ARE THE BLONDE PEOPLE.
- MM-HMM.
- AND THE FEMALE LANNISTER
IS MARRIED
TO ROBERT BARANTHEON,
WHO IS THE KING.
- IS IT BARANTHEON
OR BARATHEON?
- RIGHT, RIGHT.
- AND THEN THE OTHER
BLONDE GIRL IS THE, UH--
- CAN I GET YOU SOMETHING?
- OH, I DON'T KNOW, UM--
THREE KAMIKAZE SHOTS,
WHATEVER.
OH, MY GOD, I CAN'T BELIEVE
HE JUST DID THAT.
- WHAT'S THAT?
- SERVED ME
BEFORE YOU GUYS.
I'M REALLY AGAINST THAT.
I'M SO SORRY.
- NO, IT'S OKAY.
WE, UH--WE'VE GOT BEERS.
- NO, I MEAN, I'M SORRY
ABOUT EVERYTHING.
- OH, THAT'S FINE.
IT'S FINE.
- NO, NO, IT'S BEEN
100 YEARS OF NOT FINE.
I MEAN, 20 YEARS AGO,
YOU GUYS WOULDN'T HAVE EVEN
BEEN ALLOWED IN HERE.
- 20 YEARS--
THAT WOULD BE 1992.
- YOU'RE BOTH
REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
- OH, SHE'S DONE.
- THAT JUST HAPPENED,
DIDN'T IT?
- MM-HMM.
- YEAH, AMAZING.
- SO, THE LANNISTERS--
OKAY, SHE'S THE QUEEN.
- JAIME LANNISTER
IS THE OTHER ONE.
- JAIME AND--
- YO, YO, YO, WHAT UP, MAN?
HEY, GIVE ME ANOTHER LAGER,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
SPILLED MY LAST ONE ON MY TRIBE
SHIRT--CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT?
BUT WHATEVS,
GOT THIS THING IN '93--
MIDNIGHT MARAUDERS TOUR.
CHECK THAT OUT.
IT'S EVERYWHERE.
- MM-HMM.
- HEY, UH, WHO'S YOUR
FAVORITE MEMBER OF TRIBE?
- SMOK--SMOKE--SMOKY.
KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LOVE HIM, DUDE, MORE BEHIND
THE SCENES, BUT HE WAS, LIKE--
ALL RIGHT, GOOD.
SEE YOU GUYS AROUND, THOUGH.
- MM-HMM. OKAY.
- COOL.
- ONE MORE, ONE MORE, ONE MORE.
COME ON, SON.
BOOM.
ALL RIGHT, LATE.
- OH, HE SPUN. HE SPUN.
- WOW.
- SECOND PERSON TO NOT WAIT
FOR THEIR DRINK, BY THE WAY.
- YEP.
OKAY, LET ME
ASK YOU THIS, THEN.
WHAT'S
WITH THE BARBARIAN DUDE
WHO LOOKS LIKE
A HUGE DAVE NAVARRO?
- OKAY.
- WHO'S THAT GUY?
- OH...
I NEED A DRINK. [chuckles]
JUST FINISHED AMISTAD.
I SAW IT 3 TIMES, AND
I'LL SEE IT 100 MORE TIMES,
BECAUSE, LIKE,
I'M HAPPY TO DO IT.
IF THAT'S WHAT
THOSE GUYS WENT THROUGH,
I'M HAPPY TO SIT THROUGH IT,
YOU KNOW, 300 MORE TIMES
OR WHATEVER,
YOU KNOW, IT TAKES.
- YEAH, IT'S PRETTY INTENSE.
- SEE, MY THING IS,
IS, LIKE, I DON'T THINK
ONE PERSON SHOULD OWN
ANOTHER PERSON, PERIOD.
- I'M GLAD THAT THAT'S WHAT
YOU GOT FROM THAT MOVIE.
- THAT'S A TRUE STATEMENT.
- YEAH, I MEAN, I DON'T CARE
WHEN IT HAPPENED, ALL RIGHT?
IT SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN.
IT SHOULD NEVER OCCUR.
BUT, LIKE, I'M PREACHING
TO THE CHOIR.
YOU GUYS KNOW
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
- YEAH, WE DO.
IT'S LIKE, WHY DID
ANYBODY EVEN DO THAT?
I'M, LIKE, "NO, YOU DIDN'T.
NO, YOU DIDN'T.
WHAT YOU DOING, GIRLFRIEND?
NO, YOU DIDN'T."
I'M ASHAMED.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT'S REALLY PROBABLY OKAY,
BECAUSE YOU WEREN'T THERE.
- OKAY, WELL, WE CAN COME UP
WITH EXCUSES ALL DAY, ALL DAY.
- IT'S NOT AN EXCUSE SO MUCH.
- LET'S JUST NOT DO THAT.
LET'S NOT DO THAT.
- LOOK, HEY,
BOTTOM LINE, WE COOL.
RIGHT?
- YEAH.
- ALL RIGHT.
- YEAH, WE ARE COOL.
- WE'RE KICKITY-COOL?
- YES.
- WHAT'S THAT?
- DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING.
- NOTHING.
- OH, YOU DIDN'T--
ALL RIGHT,
FOUR MORE YEARS.
- HEY, IF IT MAKES
YOU GUYS FEEL ANY BETTER,
BLACK PEOPLE MAKE ME
REALLY UNCOMFORTABLE.
both: THANK YOU.